so we heard from mark there a little bit
about what went wrong at these
businesses I mean is there much in
common between either of them Maureen I
think there isn't there isn't I think
with Toys R Us it hadn't really invested
in this business for a long time or also
with its parent going bust in the states
that didn't help it was dependent on
that but it was up against a market
where as in the package they say lots of
people were going online but it was also
up against better players like Smith's
toys for instance was also out of town
was is much more interesting to to kids
and also Argos as well Argos was taking
its sales as well so it was just wasn't
keeping up with what was going on in
market whereas Maplin I think is it is
more that it's in a very difficult
market and again how can you develop
that specialist or it's trying it with
smart home but it's probably a bit
little and too late yeah absolutely I
mean Andrea Toys R Us as Maureen said
their real problems in the parent
company absolutely loaded up with debt
but the big-box retail format that it
traded from has that really had its day
it seems to be a general feeling right
now the the out-of-town retail pots we
went there to buy everything the big
hypermarkets we went there to everything
the Internet's really replace that that
is the one-stop shop but it's I think
it's also written that this is not just
about the internet and saying that these
stores have been you have suffered
because of the internet is only half the
story as Maureen said there are some
very very good bricks and mortar players
Primark bnm they don't even they don't
even you know trade online yet they're
doing very well it's not just about the
internet having the right product at the
right prices where we want to buy you
know I guess with toys are us as well
hobby craft another a player that's done
quite well in recent years is Morrie
mention Argos
you know they've been bought by
Sainsbury's toys are a big growing area
for them it's it's pressure from all
fronts not just the internet yeah I was
going to say about B&M which is you know
general merchandise I said that's big
stores out of town
it has toys as well and it's you know
taking some of that share and it's you
know just as exciting for people to go
to because at the price is really I
guess with Maplin though it hasn't
helped I mean it's gone through a
succession of owners during the last 15
years or so was there was a private
equity fact management buyouts then
passed along to two other private equity
firms one off to the other loaded up
with death along the way I mean this is
not a really sustainable way to run a
business is it no no it isn't and it's a
shame that you know when they were
trying to sell it that the current
owners weren't willing to put any more
money into it because and bro woollen
Mills was looking at it and pulled out
although I don't know what Edinburgh
woolen mills would have done with it
because they're mainly a clothing
retailer it's you know they couldn't
find anybody spy it because it's
obviously not viable as a business and
yet interestingly enough Rutland part as
the owner of Maplin appears to have had
quite a lot of security over some of the
freehold assets they've also been
charging fairly onerous levels of
interest as well yeah yes it's um it
doesn't give business a very good name
when that happens because it's tough
enough out there anyway and the costs
are always going up for retailers
because of business rates and employment
you know pay rises
well quite and we now have of course the
latest business rates propping through
letterbox is right now in Philip Hammond
was trying to alleviate pressure on
retailers was near it's there's still
gonna be quite a nasty shot for a lot of
them yeah I think it's it's gonna be
quite difficult for them to get the
rebates as well isn't it you go along
with that I do and I think this weather
is not going to help either we're going
to see people staying away from the
shops the fashion retailers are not
going to do well in this sort of weather
so you've got those cost pressures and
you've got a time when footfall was
likely to very significantly down for
many stores watch out for those with a
related profit warnings yeah good point
and of course Twitter Rus another nail
in the coffin was pension obligations I
mean this was one of the final things at
different alternate lis that's right and
many of many retailers that didn't offer
large wages in risk but it but at the
same time they offered pension and good
pension contributions to make up for
that so
many are saddled with big pension
obligations as as with BHS there's an
awful lot of speculation that there will
be other casualties before too long who
are you keeping it on well as Mark
mentioned the three obvious ones you've
got new look and House of Fraser that
are also already talking to landlords in
the case of new look
looking to unclothed stores debenhams
he's cutting costs you've also had a lot
of retailers that had quite severe
profit warnings after Christmas
Mothercare their shares are down at a
record low yeah there are seven percent
today less less than during the
financial crisis so you know investors
are really factoring in lot I don't you
know significant sort of concerns there
so so they would be the ones to watch
but less we forget mooring there are
winners from this as well I mean it was
noticeable Dixon's Carphone share price
was that one half percent so almost Last
Man Standing is Nixon so an awful thing
to tape it probably is going to benefit
from it and the same with you know the
toys RS then you're gonna see that those
sales are going elsewhere because we
still buy toys and it's you know it's
the like of Argos on Amazon and you know
Smiths and the entertainer that are
going to pick up some of those sales and
of course the supermarket's - yeah I
mean I guess another reason for being
worried about mother Carey's potentially
you could get a fire sale of produce now
at Toys R Us yes that is definitely
possible but they had done mean they
they had quite a severe profit warning
after Christmas so they're already
trading from a low base and that won't
help so you mentioned that possibility
of more profit warnings do you think I
mean do you sense that there could be
anything really imminent I guess it
depends on how long this cold snap yes
it will do and what happens to foot for
mean I think it would be much worse if
it was in a month's time January
February probably you know not such
great months for spending on clothing
but it's still you know they've got to
take the money some somehow and if it's
not now they've got to make it up in the
future
quite so Andrea fell stairs Maureen
Hinton good c-bro thanks for joining me